- On today's episode it's a
hotbed of Hollywood hunkery.
But who is the biggest Hollywood hotshot?
Brad versus Leo.
They're currently on top in Tinseltown.
And this epic matchup takes place
once upon a time in Hollywood.
It's the name of their movie.
- Cut.
- You embarrassed yourself like that
in front of all them goddamn people.
- Anyway.
Here's how it works.
Round one, box office.
Round two, tomatometer.
Round three, awards.
And we'll do a wildcard round.
Then you will determine the winner.
One will continue to be an A-list actor,
and the other is doomed to a fate
of summer stock forever more.
Let's get it on.
- I got a six pack in the back,
thought we'd order a pizza.
- [Leo] All right.
- Round one, box office.
Brad Pitt has had a
longer career than Leo,
and has accrued more total
dollars at the Cineplex,
so does that mean he wins this round?
Or is he just older?
- Web of lies.
- Brad's lifetime domestic
haul stands at $4.29 billion.
While Leo's is $3.64 billion.
Let's take a closer look.
Without Pitt's eight
second cameo in Deadpool 2,
that total number for him
slides down to $3.98 billion.
And Leo has a much
higher per movie average.
$152 million for him,
$110 million for Brad.
So is it quantity over quality?
If you're asking me about french fries,
the answer's always yes.
When it comes to movies, I like a fella
who has a guaranteed smash hit every time.
Brad has made 39 flicks,
and some real gems in there.
But Leo, he's only done 24 movies
and he throws a haymaker with
every new talkie he releases.
I did the math, somebody
here did the math,
and by the time Leo is 60, and Brad Pitt
has turned into a little wrinkly baby,
DiCaprio will overtake
him at the box office.
So DiCaprio wins the round.
(dinging)
And he's up one nothing.
- I'm the king of the world.
Woo!
- Round two, tomatometer.
Well if it's quality you want,
look no further than the caliber of film
these gentlemen put out.
(speaking foreign language)
They're both the rare actor that can brag
about having a career fresh
average on the tomatometer.
Brad's films rates 64.5% on average.
Leo trails him by only a
couple points, at 62.8%.
Both these fellas tie for
highest individual movie score, at 95%.
Brad earned his for 12 Years a Slave.
Leo for Catch Me if you Can.
- [Woman] Would you like
a drink after takeoff?
- Milk?
- Brad wasn't the star of his movie,
but he did produce it and
he won an Oscar for it.
- It is a fact.
A plain and simple fact.
That what is true and right
is true and right for all.
- So what are the films that
are weighing the boys down?
Well Leo has a big fat
goose egg on his resume,
that being for Critters 3.
- You can't expect us to
believe this horseshit.
- It's at 0%.
That's not his fault, he was like nine.
(gurgling)
Brad's lowest is 4% for Cool World.
And I am shocked it took me that long
to reference that classic.
Remember Cool World?
(thunking and chuckling)
That 4% would be a lot higher if
Who Framed Roger Rabbit
hadn't already come out.
No?
I'm getting the word no,
that apparently that
movie's still terrible.
(laughing)
This round comes down to who's been
doing it better for longer.
I got Pitt by the slightest
of margins in both regards.
Brad ekes out a victory in this round.
(dinging)
And we're tied at one a piece.
- 'Cause business is a booming.
(laughing)
- Round three, awards.
Look movies are fun and all.
But we know they're not worth anything
unless they win a trophy.
Same goes for actors.
And both these studs have
built quite a resume.
Brad Pitt, you know how many
total awards this guy has won?
67!
67.
He's two away from Bill and Ted's
favorite number of all time.
- 69, dudes.
- And he's been nominated 152 times.
The guy from Cool World has won 67 awards.
(laughing)
Well good luck competing
in this category, Leo.
I'm sorry, what's that?
Boys and girls I'm just getting word,
Leonardo DiCaprio has won 97 awards.
And he's been nominated 209 times.
So he has more nominations, more wins,
and a better nom to win ratio than Brad.
But how about with the important awards?
There's one ceremony that stands
head and shoulders above the others.
However, each fellow is tied
with four MTV Movie Awards.
So let's go to the lowly Oscars instead.
Leo finally took home Oscar gold
with his win for The Revenant.
Two years before, Brad got his first Oscar
for producing 12 Years a Slave.
So they're tied with one win apiece,
and six nominations each.
But, Leo's have all come from acting.
Brad has nominated thrice for acting,
thrice for producing.
And what are we talking about here today?
Movie stardom.
Producing is great, like
you pick up a phone,
you say how are things going onset?
I'm sure more goes into it than that.
But I'm giving the win to Leo
(dinging)
because he's won more times for acting.
(goofy music)
Wild card round.
Acting range.
Yes acting range.
Look, it's easy to be a leading man
when you're good looking,
but which actor has the most range
when it comes to a roll, Brad or Leo?
Leo first came to prominence playing
a mentally disabled teenager
in What's Eating Gilbert Grape.
He would go on to play everything from
a drug addicted basketball player,
to a reclusive innovator,
to a maniac stockbroker.
- So let's knock this
motherfucker outta the park!
Oh!
- And when he acts with Kate Winslet
he can either be a bored suburban husband,
or really wet and cold.
Good range, kid.
But let me tell you something about Brad,
stoner, psychopath, cult
leader, bare knuckle boxer,
thief, outlaw, Nazi
hunter, and zombie slayer.
And he can do all these
things while eating
a tremendous amount of calories onscreen.
Pitt has consumed almost 5,000
calories onscreen, all told.
Which is incidentally my
record at Golden Corral.
(burping)
Leo does get points for
eating actual bison liver.
Like an actual bison liver, he ate it.
And he was a damn good junior
thief in Growing Pains.
Remember when he was on the TV show?
But the winner of the round is the man
who is possibly the
dumbest personal trainer
in the history of cinema, Mr. Brad Pitt.
(dinging)
- Well like, you're so plugged into
the intelligence community.
- So at the end of the wildcard round
we find ourselves in a dead heat.
It's tied at two.
So my tiebreaker will be
based purely on my gut.
And my gut is saying, go with
the guy with the better abs.
And this is no slight to Leo,
but have you seen Brad's six-pack?
Seriously, it's not even fair.
The guy eats in every scene in every movie
he's ever been in, and
he still looks like that.
- Ah, you sir, yeah you do the honors.
- Brad gets the win as the
biggest Hollywood hotshot.
- It's official old buddy.
I'm a has been.
- That's what losing sounds like.
- But that's just my superficial take,
the real judge is you, the viewer.
Head to the comment section right now,
and vote by telling us your winner.
Is it the guy from The Beach,
or the dude from Tree of Life?
Good luck understanding
either one of those films.
Thanks for tuning in.
I'm Mark Ellis.
And I will do no crunches today.
(rock music)